hi my name's jig Watson I'm a co
creative director of corridor digital
we're a digital entertainment studio
that specializes in narrative video game
inspired content tech experiments
vlogging
are you practicing what you're doing
yeah I have to do like an intro and I
have to show like a bunch of these
old-timey guys that I'm actually kind of
[ __ ] and I'm also a licensed
entertainment lawyer in the state of
California I can really button up that
ending go to long we're here in Salt
Lake City we're going to get the car we
got to make it all the way at Park City
take two hours or so I don't know I've
never been up there and I don't know the
condition you never been to a place
where so many people don't have cars
there's probably less than a thousand
cars in here and we're going to get one
you're like okay that's pretty cool it's
got a nice back plate and space and
everything but wait check out this o new
Dodge Durango whiskey all-wheel drive
Park City you get a lot of stuff there
yeah yeah I hear you guys eating okay
yeah a day today guys thanks you see how
nice everyone is here did you see that
guy more people are like that in LA it'd
be a lot nicer place to live I just got
in this car and I've never been in one
of these cars before so I don't know how
to open the hood I'm used to driving
motorcycles an old truck it's a really
nice day out here in beautiful Utah
carvaka
we're cruising along had not a salt lake
towards Park City going along the AE
thinking a little couple more miles
shall we get to the next stop
freeway that we need to head we're
chatting it up we're talking about
everything and
we went 37 minutes in the wrong
direction down the 80 and now we're
heading back another 37 minutes so we
can actually go to where the hell we
were supposed to go oh hey welcome to
Park City where Carl and I are going to
go out show you the sights and sounds
we've never been to either the first
thing that we've found people are super
nice here so much so that for every
person who doesn't say hi to us I will
make a snow angel in their honor
imagine if you tried to say hi to
everybody that you passed in Los Angeles
how many snow angels you have to do do
do with smog angels you just stand there
and you just do this
that one's house dear guy in the green
jacket with the ski mask on that didn't
say hi to me when I said hello made this
snow angel okay and your life watch over
you and bring you general happiness I
better really be more enthusiastic about
this I really don't want to do this all
day
black guy with the porn stache I am
partially to blame
I should have committed to you more oh
this one's the word and that my friends
is a lesson about commitment no I think
I think I'm pretty sure we're gone right
away
carmichael and i are going to the brand
panel where we're going to speak it
starts at 11:00 it's ten o'clock now so
we're going to get there do a half hour
of meeting greeting shaking cans there's
going to be a lot of words used like
influencer and and tune in and upselling
and downselling thank you so much for
putting all the comments in the video
Carmichael was just looking through them
very thoroughly as soon as I get there I
will be frantically scrolling through my
phone also reading Carmichael's
executive notes on what the general
themes have been I hope I'm going the
right way to go that's a Croatian flag
those are my people that conversation
that I had back there that girl goes
here you are you lost you want to get
Minnesota nice treatment you have to be
able to speak with a Minnesota accent so
for example oh yeah I think I mean I hey
I couldn't tell you one way or another I
just know we're trying to get the Main
Street
yeah it's dumb if you look at this with
you gets maybe Heber and take a left
it's just a one block this eventually
runs parallel to me Oh perfect yeah York
like a minute or two thank ya hey there
all right
fern we are here okay what it was park
so weird split look like anyone's here
there's plenty of parking here here's
optionality flourish this is hi my name
is Jake walk o creative director of
corridor digital or digital
entertainment studios specializing in
video game inspired narrative content
tech experiments and blogging with two
YouTube channel with a subscriber base
of around five million their content on
Hulu sliced is low and we specialize in
Nereus video game inspired confidence
tech experiments in vlogging Liam to
youtube channel under Irish appropriate
she's our video of you Amazon flying
through YouTube YouTube red go 9d
Facebook mix them and also like this
[Music]
will you go buy some gloves need the
book your ever head doing great day
Harry your hands are freezing
they kill me but I'm gonna do it yeah
John good for you yeah thank you doing
alright
yeah do you look for the skin cream all
right
howdy hello just now it's getting
started here after just a little bit of
doing it I think I understand with like
PewDiePie and other people are saying
when they say that this force positivity
on YouTube this is this is tough you
can't just go out there and like decide
that you're going to be emotional
however you're going to be you got to
actually put forth the effort and it's
good work too I think we're doing good
work here hands going oh my god it's
pretty good it's for the people of Park
City I think we've made the world a
little bit of a better place today
I don't want brag but you know there's a
lot of more positive energy out there
now that we've done our part and I think
those people those lonely hearts out
there that couldn't find it to say hello
I think next time they're going to say
hello and anyways I just want to thank
the good people of Park City could've
done without you guys oh and all you
cold-hearted Angelenos that have come
out here
Walter replication of an IV like with
its marbles got 300 million dollars to
go to make ironmans
we're not going to go out and try to
make a team for my event at the end of
the day you got my finger still without
Johnny had your things well most from
the top of these things everybody like
but he's with everyone the Hicks you
can't really build a business without
you know how many shows it's been on TV
a lot of them got these up go to HBO and
so for me to purely being old to guys
like it's helped with how much you get
the money back right that's not a good
proposition for without looking for a
lot by the guide your son thing
here's no I can make sure you enjoy that
that didn't exist five years ago you
didn't make this whole series on and and
we're still sort of figuring that out
but born what we do is a closer and
closer we get to finding out actually
where that water you have moment is
coming in the next year two years it's
really going to be as a consistent call
of residual do you get off and now
Carmichael I has two more nights where
we don't know where we're going to stay
you can't double penis Oh what's up